>> IF YOU LOVE MY BODY, JUST
RUSH THE BORDER. NEW VIDEO SHOWS
CHAOS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
10,000 MIGRANTS CRAMMING
THEMSELVES UNDER A BRIDGE IN DEL
RIO, TEXAS. OFFICIALS SAY 10,000
MORE IMMIGRANTS ARE ON THE WAY
TO JOIN THEM. A MASSIVE
MAKESHIFT SHELTER HIGHLIGHTING
HOW BAD IT IS OUR OWN BILL
MELUGIAN SHOWING HOW MIGRANTS
CAN CROSS THE DAM AND MAKE THEIR
WAY TO TEXAS WITH NO RESISTANCE.
THE WHITE HOUSE REFUSES TO SAY
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS A CRISIS.
THEY WON'T CALL IT A CRISIS.
REPUBLICANS ARE FURIOUS WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THE FACT THAT HE'S
ALLOWING IT TO HAPPEN. WATCH.
>> IT IS THE MOST HORRIFIC THING
I'VE SEEN. IT'S PACKED IN AS A
MASS OF HUMANITY.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, YOU CAN'T TRUST THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION. IT WOULD
BE LIKE TRUSTING HARVEY
WINESTEIN WITH YOUR DAUGHTER.
>> HE IS FAILING AND HE'S
WILLFULLY DISREGARDING THE DUTY
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THIS IS NOT AUTHORIZED BY THE
STATE OF TEXAS. IT'S NOT WELCOME
BY THE STATE OF TEXAS OR ANY
OTHER REPUBLICAN STATE THAT I
KNOW. AND THEY'RE NOT INVITED.
>> THEY'RE SAYING IT'S BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT REFUSED TO FLY THE
HAITIAN IMMIGRANTS, MOSTLY, BACK
TO HAITI.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> TRAGEDY UPON TRAGEDY
COMPOUNDED BY AN INEPT
ADMINISTRATION THAT REFUSES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS CRISIS IS
PRESENT.
AND FOR AN ADMINISTRATION TO
CLAIM TO PRIORITIZE COVID OVER
EVERYTHING, THE VACCINATION RATE
IN HAITI IS .1%.
8,000 OF THOSE MIGRANTS UNDER
THAT BRIDGE ARE FROM HAITI AS
YOU POINTED OUT.
WE KNOW IN McALLEN, TEXAS, THERE
WAS A 15% COVID POSITIVE RATE IN
THE 7,000 MIGRANTS THAT HAD BEEN
RELEASED INTO THAT TOWN IN
RECENT MONTHS.
HOWEVER, REMEMBER, NEW YORK CITY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS SHUT DOWN AT 3%.
WHICH IS IT?
WHAT IS THE PRIORITY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
NOW I KNOW THAT THEY'RE FOLDING
INTO THIS HUMONGOUS BILL WITH
OUR TAX DOLLARS WILL FUND
AMNESTY FOR ALL.
IN THE INTERIM, IT'S A COMPLETE
CRISIS.
THEY HAVE NO ADEQUATE SHELTER.
WHAT LOOKS LIKE A PARTY IS AN
ABSOLUTE CESSPOOL.
THEY'RE STANDING IN THEIR OWN
FECES.
THERE'S NO RUNNING WATER THAT'S
CLEAN.
NO POTABLE WATER, NO FOOD
SOURCES.
INSTEAD OF BEING PUT BACK TO A
SAFE PLACE WHERE THEY'RE FROM,
THEY'RE BEING LEFT THERE IN
SQUALOR WITH AN ADMINISTRATION
AND MAIN STREAM MEDIA THAT TURNS
ITS HEAD.
>> THEY CAN'T TURN THEIR HEAD
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE FOX HAS BEEN
FLYING A DRONE OVER THE AREA.
JUST TO CAPTURE THE FOOTAGE.
SO, PEOPLE CAN SEE EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND THE NUMBER OF DESPERATE
HAITIANS, SOUTH AMERICANS,
MEXICANS WHO ARE TRYING TO GET
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
BUT BILL MALUGIAN HAS BEEN
REPORTING THERE'S A TEMPORARY
FLIGHT RESTRICTION FOR TWO WEEKS
SO WE WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE THESE
PICTURES.
YOU HAVE THREE KIDS THAT YOU
KNOW OF.
YOU DO HAVE A BABY.
AND SO, WHEN BABIES PUT THEIR
HANDS OVER THEIR EYES, THEY
THINK NO ONE CAN SEE THEM.
SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO REMOVE THE FOX NEWS
DRONE SO NO ONE CAN SEE HOW BAD
IT'S GOTTEN IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
>> THAT'S THE PAT HERB.
HE CREATES A CRISIS.
THEN TRIES TO COVER IT UP AND
LIE ABOUT IT.
FIRST THEY WOULDN'T LET THE
MEDIA IN TO WHERE THEY HAD KIDS
IN CAGES.
THEN THEY FLEW THEM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
AND THEN --
>> THEY LIFTED THE BAN A FEW
HOURS AGO.
IT WAS A LOT OF PUSHBACK WHEN IT
WAS OBVIOUSLY A MOTIVATED BAN.
>> THEN THEY LIE, THEY SAY
EVERYTHING IS FINE, IT'S NOT A
CRISIS.
IT'S TRUMP'S FAULT.
WHICH ONE IS IT?
HERE'S WHY THE MEDIA DOESN'T
COVER IT.
FOX IS THE ONLY ONE WITH A
DRONE.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS IS A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO WORK OUT OF NEW
YORK OR DC, THEY DON'T EVEN SEE
TEXAS AS PART OF THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE SILLY RED STATE WAY
DOWN SOUTH.
MAYBE THEY'LL GO TO AUSTIN TO
SOUTH-BY-SOUTHWEST.
THEY'LL GET A KICK OUT OF THE
MUSIC AND THE BAR.
AND THEY'LL FLY BACK AND SAY
I'VE BEEN TO TEXAS.
THEY DON'T GO TO BROWNSVILLE OR
McALLEN OR LAREDO.
>> NEITHER DOES VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS, OBVIOUSLY.
>> NEITHER DOES SHE, RIGHT?
SO IF YOU HAVE 10,000 HAITIANS
OR RANDOM GUYS FROM NICARAGUA OR
MEXICO LINED UP POURING INTO A
SMALL TOWN, A RANCHING TOWN,
FAMILIES WHO HAVE KIDS IN SCHOOL
AND SMALL BUSINESSES, YOU'RE
GOING TO OVERWHELM THAT TOWN.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THAT KIND OF
INFLUX OF RANDOM PEOPLE LIKE
THAT, UNVAKSED, NO DOCUMENTS, NO
EDUCATION, NO ENGLISH.
YOU'RE GOING TO POUR ACROSS A
BORDER IN A TOWN LIKE THAT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CRYING OUT FOR
HELP.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T CARE.
THEY'RE NOT AFFECTED BY IT.
IT'S A 27-HOUR DRIVE FROM TEXAS
TO NEW YORK.
MIGHT AS WELL BE AUSTRALIA.
>> THAT'S A MUCH LONGER DRIVE
WITH NO BRIDGE.
>> HARDER TO DRIVE TO AUSTRALIA.
>> GOOD POINT, JESSE.
HOW DO THE DEMOCRATS MAKE A
POLITICAL WIN?
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN A STATE TRYING TO
GO FROM PURPLISH TO BLUE.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRAT LAWMAKERS WHO
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING AND SEE HOW
THE TOWNS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS, TO JESSE'S POINT,
ARE COMPLETELY OVERRUN.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO MAKE
HAY WITH NEXT YEAR IN THE
MIDTERMS.
>> I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
LE I THINK IT'S A VALID
QUESTION, KENNEDY.
I THINK THE WAY TO START IS BY
TELLING THE STORY OF THE
HAITIANS AT THAT BORDER.
AND HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
WE KNOW THIS -- THAT MOST OF THE
HAITIANS THAT ARE AT THAT BORDER
WOULD QUALIFY FOR TEMPORARY
PROTECTIVE STATUS UNDER AMERICAN
LAW AND INTERNATIONAL LAW.
MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH TWO EARTHQUAKES, TWO
HURRICANES.
MANY OF THEM LEFT THE COUNTRY OF
HAITI.
THEY GOT ON SHIPS AND WENT TO
BRAZIL.
THEY DIDN'T WALK ON FOOT FROM
BRAZIL TO AMERICA'S SOUTHERN
BORDER, A JOURNEY THAT TAKES 15
MONTHS, RIGHT?
THEY'RE ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY'RE WAITING TO QUALIFY FOR
ASYLUM.
MANY OF THEM CAN BECAUSE OF
TITLE 52 THAT SAYS BECAUSE OF
HEALTH RESTRICTIONS, YOU CANNOT
CROSS THAT BORDER.
BECAUSE OF CLOGGED IMMIGRATION
COURTS, THEY ARE NOT SEEING A
JUDGE.
THIS IS A STORY ABOUT DELAYS IN
THE IMMIGRATION COURTS AND
UNMODERNIZED IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
HAS CAUSED MANY OF THESE FOLKS
WHO WOULD QUALIFY FOR TEMPORARY
PROTECTIVE STATUS TO BE -- AS
YOU SAID, EMILY, TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THERE'S A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BY THE PEOPLE
WHO WILL QUALIFY FOR
HUMANITARIAN ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE A GIVING COUNTRY, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE LADY LIBERTY
A COUPLE OF MILES FROM HERE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS -- WHO WE
SHOULD BE GIVING TO.
>> SO THEY'RE PRIORITIZED
ABOVE --
>> NO, NOT ABOUT PRIORITIZING
OVER THEM.
>> THAT'S THE ARGUMENT YOU'RE
MAKING RIGHT NOW.
>> NO, NO.
>> WHATEVER THE ADMINISTRATION
IS, THERE'S A FIXED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
>> VERY TRUE.
RIGHT?
BUT I'M SAYING THERE'S LAWS AND
THERE'S A LAW IN PLACE ON THE
BOOKS FOR THEM TO QUALIFY.
TEMPORARY PROTECTIVE STATUS.
THEY WOULD QUALIFY.
THEY'RE NOT SEEING A JUDGE
BECAUSE THE COURTS ARE SO
OVERRUN.
THEY ARE SO CLOGGED THAT IT
MIGHT BE TWO OR THREE YEARS
BEFORE THEY GET TO COURT.
>> THE DIFFERENCE, RICHARD, IS
YOU HAVE AMERICANS STILL
STRANDED IN AFGHANISTAN WHO
BIDEN HAS ABANDONED AND THEY'RE
LETTING IN --
>> YOU CAN'T --
>> YOU'RE MIXING APPLES AND
ORANGES.
>> DON'T QUALIFY --
>> VERSUS -- TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> OVERSEAS, MAKE THEM PRIORITY.
>> VERIFY THE MANIFEST.
>> CAN'T VERIFY 10,000 PEOPLE A
DAY COMING INTO A SMALL TOWN,
GREG?
>> IT IS INTERESTING.
THE GOVERNMENT TRIES TO TAKE
DOWN THE DRONES.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION,
THEY WOULD HAVE INVITED THE
PRESS DOWN TO SEE EVERYTHING.
I GUESS BIDEN ONLY APPROVES OF
DRONES IF THEY'RE KILLING
PEOPLE.
IF THIS COVERAGE, THIS COVERAGE,
THIS AMAZING, YOU KNOW, FOOTAGE
WERE ON ANY OTHER NETWORK, LET'S
SAY NBC, IT WOULD WIN EMMYS
BECAUSE THE VISUALS HAVE THE
POWER OF CREATING A REAL TRUE
NARRATIVE THAT RICHARD SHOULD
APPLAUD BECAUSE IT WOULD TELL
THE STORY THAT HE WOULD WANT TO
HEAR.
THESE VISUALS ARE STRIKING.
THEY'RE FORCING THE MAIN STREAM
MEDIA TO GET OFF THEIR BUTTS.
THESE ARE IMAGES THAT HONESTLY
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
BUT IT TELLS YOU WHY NOTHING
CHANGES.
IT'S BECAUSE THE MEDIA ARE THE
GATEKEEPERS OF THE -- THE LEFT
ARE THE MEDIA GATEKEEPERS FOR
THE MEDIA.
THERE'S ONE SMALL LIKE TRICKLE
OF INJUSTICE ANYWHERE UNDER
REPUBLICANS, THE MEDIA WILL
AMPLIFY IT.
RIGHT?
BUT YOU COULD HAVE MONTHS OF
THIS.
WE'VE HAD MONTHS OF THIS.
A LOT OF IT, SUFFERING.
A LOT OF IT, UNMITIGATED
SUFFERING.
IT TAKES FOX -- AND FOX'S
VISUAL, BILL MALUGI ARC N TO
FORCE THE MEDIA TO A CORNER TO
DO THIS WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN POWER.
YOU HAVE TO SHAME THEM TO DO
THEIR JOBS. BUT THIS IS WHY WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE THE MONOPOLY -- THE
MONOPOLY OF THOUGHT IN THE
MEDIA, WHICH IS ALIGNED WITH --
WITH DEMOCRATS MAKES THIS KIND
OF COVERAGE SO RARE THAT I -- I
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY GO FORWARD
WHEN NOW THEY CAN SEE THIS.
THIS IS AWARD-WINNING STUFF.
>> NBC GAVE THIS FOUR SECONDS --
COVERAGE OF THIS ISSUE IN MAIN
STREAM MEDIA BESIDES US HAS
DECLINED 94% WHILE THE SURGE
ITSELF OF THESE PEOPLE, THESE
HUMANS, HAS INCREASED BY OVER
300%. TO YOUR POINT.
>> THEY KNO